dangling plot threads and dumb decisions
Avatar the way of water is gorgeous epic
and moving but these plot holes prove it
isn't perfect
after the return of Colonel quarrich
Jake and his family decide to go into
hiding to protect the omotakaya clan
from the Colonel's wrath since the
colonel only wants revenge on his human
form's killer Jake assumes quarridge
will leave the omotakaya alone but going
into hiding doesn't guarantee anything
the plan hinges on the assumption that
quarrych knows what Jake knows Jake
didn't exactly announce to the resource
development Administration aka the RDA
that he'd be leaving the jungle quarrich
has no reason to believe Jake and his
family would leave their home in the
Hallelujah mountains where they'd be
mostly safe thanks to the flux vortex in
the omitakaya's guerrilla warfare
tactics it follows that he would try to
find Jake in the Hallelujah mountains
first even if korich couldn't seize the
Hallelujah mountains he would certainly
be capable of taking individual Navi
prisoners like he already did with
spider and almost stood with Jake's
children if the omotakaya tried to
explain that Jake fled quarch might not
believe them after all he didn't believe
the innocent metcaina tribes when they
told him they hadn't seen Jake and he
still torched their homes it was only by
a Stroke of Luck that the omitakaya
tribe was spared to the same fate Jake
has a huge bounty on his head in the way
of water but the plot may be overstating
his importance does the RDA really think
that taking out a single person will
silence the navi Insurrection for good
it makes sense for quarch to be
single-mindedly focused on finding Jake
he doesn't care about the other Navi he
just wants revenge but kwarich isn't the
only one making decisions at the RDA
certainly killing Jake would deal a huge
blow to the resistance he was the one
who rallied the navi to Victory 15 years
ago and without him it would take them a
long time to regroup Jake is also one of
the few characters on Pandora who has
inside knowledge of the RDA but he's not
the only one who knows how to use human
technology and he's not the only one
capable of organizing an army this
oversight is especially apparent in the
battle at Sea viewers will notice that
tonawari gathers his clan into an
imposing battle formation and on very
short notice too this moment reminds
audiences that the navi are quite
capable of organizing themselves clearly
the movement to free Pandora will live
on even if Jake died so maybe the last
thing the RDA wants is to turn Jake into
a martyr when they learn that their kids
are being held hostage in the forest
Jake Anthony teary swoop and to rescue
them it's a good thing that they're able
to respond so quickly but it's a little
surprising that their rescue party
consists of only two people why didn't
they ask their clan for reinforcements
perhaps with backup they could have
prevented spiders capture you'd think
Jake Anthony teary would pull out all
the stops to save their children Jake
and his son were both equipped with
throat mics so it should have been
relatively easy for Jake to radio for
help after all it's not like Jake and
his family are the only Navi using human
technology considering that Jake and the
omitakaya clan have been staging
guerrilla warfare against the RDA for
the past year it's hard to believe that
all the navi aren't equipped with throat
mics while there may not be an in-story
reason for this the choice at least
makes sense from a storytelling
perspective most likely the filmmakers
wanted to keep the cast to a manageable
size and that meant not dragging a bunch
of additional characters into the fight
the film is about Jake and his family so
it makes sense that only these
characters would be involved if nothing
else this is one movie Epic in scale but
maintaining an intimate Focus is still
no doubt some viewers were frustrated
watching the scene knowing that Jake
could have made a smarter move
without unobtainium the events of Avatar
would have never happened after all it
was the whole reason the RDA funded the
mission on Pandora there's this little
gray rock sells for 20 million a kilo
that's the only reason yet unobtainium
seems to be the last thing on the rda's
Mind these days General Ardmore insists
that the company's new objective is
colonization not mining because Earth is
pretty much a lost cause at this point
it's understandable why the rda's
priorities might have changed 15 years
have passed on Earth more than enough
time for war and climate change to
render it nearly unlivable perhaps all
the unobtainium in the world won't do
them any good because soon everyone on
the planet is going to need to jump ship
still it's a little strange that the
film never mentions unobtanium not even
once he would think that the miraculous
material would come in handy for the RDA
if they want to expand their colony and
crush the navi resistance the rda's
purpose is further obfuscated in the
scene where tolkun Hunter makes scoresby
extracts a chemical called Amrita from
the toku's brain scoresby brags that
Amrita can effectively stop aging
entirely making it Eclipse unobtainium
as the most valuable resource on Pandora
he also adds that Amrita is paying for
everything on Pandora which seems to
contradict the notion that the RDA cares
only about colonization while it makes
sense that Amrita is extremely valuable
it seems doubtful it would be of much
use to the humans back on a dying planet
Earth
Colonel quarrich goes to some Great
Lengths to bait Jake and capture his
children even though he already has one
of Jake's children in his custody okay
spider is technically Jake's adoptive
son but Jake still cares about the boy
why lay out an elaborate trap for Jake
when the RDA already has something Jake
wants obviously the real reason quartz
doesn't hold spider hostage is clear
spider is his son and as one key scene
from the climax demonstrates quarch
loves his son more than he hates Jake
I'm getting all emotional I might just
give you a big wet kiss yet once again
quarrych isn't the one in charge and it
seems like General Ardmore has no such
qualms about using spider that way why
doesn't she just order kwarich to Ransom
his son the only reason why the RDA
might not take advantage of the prisoner
they already had would be if quorge was
convinced that spider was genuinely
cooperating with his captors but General
Ardmore would need to be convinced too
and somehow it seems doubtful she would
automatically trust the boy like kwarich
Avatar the way of water isn't the first
movie in the Avatar franchise to
contradict itself about the science of
Pandora the first film made it clear
that humans couldn't survive long
without a mask in Pandora's atmosphere
specifically they'd be unconscious after
20 seconds and dead after 4 minutes but
that doesn't seem to stop courage from
opening an airlock and then firing on
Jake for a heck of a lot longer than 20
seconds though granted he's basically a
finely tuned murder machine and would
have no trouble holding his breath that
long
but the sequel also plays a little fast
and loose with the specifics early in
the movie spider establishes a key rule
of World building he tells the navi you
can breathe earth air for hours I can
only breathe yours for like 10 seconds
yet quarrich who now inhabits a navi
Avatar with recombinant DNA recom for
short doesn't seem to follow this rule
quarrich is quite comfortable breathing
Pandora's air as well as the earth air
inside the RDA compound aside from a
brief moment when quarge sucks in a few
gulps from a gas mask before talking to
spider one possible explanation here is
that the recoms were bred to be able to
breathe in both Earth's atmosphere and
that of Pandora though it might have
been nice if the film had taken a moment
to mention that just breathe
breathe to be honest courage attempting
to ride a Banshee wasn't the smartest
move surely kwarriage could tell that
spider was hoping the colonel would
humiliate himself however that's not a
plot hole in itself because it makes
perfect sense for quarrych's character
he's stubborn and wants to prove he can
do anything that Jake can do so that's
why he takes the bait however one moment
from the Banshee scene doesn't quite add
up quarrych has seen tumbling off the
cliff on the back of a banshee much like
Jake did in the first film only to
emerge Victorious a minute later how
does he learn so quickly clearly the
colonel is a novice to Banshee writing
not even knowing that he should muzzle
the Banshee before trying to mount it
according to the rules established in
the first movie quarridge could have
only tamed the Beast by completing the
bond which involves linking the nerve
receptors in his cue to the Banshees
receptors but how does quarridge know
about this most likely the RDA knows
about this Ritual from Jake's video logs
from the first movie but whether or not
quarch knows is a different story
knowing quarrych he wouldn't do his
homework he has a pretty rudimentary
grasp of the navi language to the point
that spider says he has the vocabulary
of a three-year-old these Avatar movies
sure do have a grudge against babies
you're like a baby
anyway the point is the colonel would
have probably only researched the bare
minimum necessary for the mission and
unless he predicted that his guide would
goad him into trying to tame a Banshee
the bonding ritual probably wasn't in
his plans
the first half of the way of water seems
to be building toward quarrich and his
fellow recoms trying to go undercover
among the navi that's why they go out of
their way to tame banshees and learn the
language so they can get close enough to
Jake to kill him and then destroy the
navi Insurrection from the inside yet
this plot thread is abandoned halfway
through the movie it's understandable
why the filmmakers didn't take this
route the undercover angle was already
explored in the first movie with Jake
and honestly the recoms wouldn't have
gotten very far they wouldn't fool a
real navi for an instant however the way
that kwarich and his team switch gears
is a little contrived the RDA
conveniently picks up a signal from a
rogue gunship which sends the plot in a
New Direction everything that happens in
the second half of the movie hinges on
quarge guessing correctly that the
unidentified aircraft will lead him
straight to Jake that's an awfully lucky
guess up until this point quarrette had
every reason to believe that Jake was in
the Hallelujah mountains besides it
feels implausible that General Ardmore
would let quarrych travel Halfway Around
Pandora on a hunch there's one plot hole
in avatar The Way of water so annoy
enormous that Reddit users called it out
almost immediately after the film came
out where is Jake's Army when he needs
it most the Met kaina Clan had Jake's
back throughout the first hostage
exchange on the ship and the ensuing
battle but the moment that the chief's
daughter Soraya is rescued the clan is
nowhere to be found leaving Jake and his
family to fend for themselves so why did
they bail perhaps the Met kaina
retreated after Soraya was safe because
they no longer had a personal stake in
the conflict or maybe they were
physically unable to help one Reddit
user speculated they couldn't get past
the fire on the water that is a fair
point though it seems like the mech
hyena might have been able to swim under
meanwhile another redditor offered a
solid explanation even if it wasn't an
in-universe explanation saying that the
real focus of this part was the family
unit had the filmmakers included the
whole Army in the final battle it would
have become too crowded trying to focus
on any characters other than Jake and
his family would honestly have only
heard the story
[Music]
foreign